Hey Thoughty2 Here,
The 30th US president Calvin Coolidge liked
to have his head rubbed with petroleum jelly
whilst eating his breakfast and Abraham Lincoln
was also a licensed bartender.
But how do you become president of the United
States?
There are only three official pre-requisites
to becoming president:
You must have been born in the United States
of America.
You must have lived in America for 14 years
and you must be at least 35 years of age.
But even if you fit all three of these requirements,
there are a bunch of unofficial rules to become
president.
Such as:
Be Male.
There has never been a Female president of
the US.
Don't have a serious criminal record.
George W. Bush had a DUI conviction in 1976.
But do you really think people are going to
vote for an armed robber?
Don't be fat.
There have only been five presidents who were
technically obese, the largest of these was
27th president, William Howard Taft, who weighed
in at 335 pounds.
But since the days of TV, there hasn't been
a single obese president.
Be straight.
The US public has never elected an openly
gay president.
The president with the strongest evidence
of being homosexual was 15th president James
Buchanan.
Be a devout Christian.
76% of Americans are Christians and 92% believe
in a higher power so don't think you're getting
in if you're an atheist, or any other religion.
Be tall and handsome.
In approximately 75% of elections the taller
and better-looking candidate wins.
You're not allowed to sweat or make the American
public aware that you have any normal bodily
functions whatsoever.
During the infamous 1960, Kennedy vs Nixon
debates.
Kennedy was a natural on camera whereas a
more timid Nixon, having just come off the
flu, started to sweat profusely under the
hot studio lights.
Kennedy later won the vote 49.7% to 49.5%.
Polls revealed that more than half of all
voters had been influenced by the debates.
And finally, don't claim to have invented
the internet, in 2000 Al Gore lost the presidential
election partially because, whilst ticking
off a list of accomplishments he let slip
"During my service in the United States Congress,
I took initiative in creating the Internet".
So what's the lesson here?
If you want to be president, never say anything
which can be taken out of context or is just
plain wrong.
Sadly, if you don't fit all of these criteria,
the US public are unlikely to vote for you.
So you're a Straight, Law-Abiding, Thin, Tall,
Handsome, Male, American Christian.
What next?
Well, it also helps to be wealthy, charismatic,
confident, an exemplary public speaker, have
impeccable body language, an Ivy League education,
lots and lots of wealthy friends in powerful
places, European ancestry, a wife and kids,
strong debating skills and a clear perspective
on all current issues.
Providing you tick all the boxes, how do you
start your presidential campaign?
The first step is to secure a good job in
US politics or the military.
In the last 70 years, every major party presidential
nominee has been either a sitting or former
US senator, governor, vice-president or five-star
general.
Second, you need to form an exploratory committee,
the purpose of this committee is to test the
waters, raise money for your campaign and
decide if you really have what it takes to
become president.
This can begin up to two years before the
election.
During this time if you receive significant
interest from the media, campaign strategists
and potential donors you can formally declare
your candidacy and launch your presidential
campaign.
You will also need to choose a vice president
candidate.
The third step is campaigning, this means
travelling throughout the country to gain
the support of the public for your political
party and candidacy.
This usually involves holding rallies, participating
in debates, kissing babies, wining and dining
and posing for photographs.
Like most parties, you should start your campaigning
in Iowa, New Hampshire and South Carolina,
because these states hold the first contests
of the campaign in January before the elections.
So good performance here can make or break
your campaign.
You will also need to spend a lot of money
on advertising.
Barack Obama's party spent $1.123 billion
during his campaign.
In the final weeks before the elections, the
contenders focus their efforts on the so-called
"battleground" states, where the electorate
is more or less evenly divided and hence the
outcome is uncertain.
In these key remaining states, campaign volunteers
and paid staff furiously work the telephones
and go door to door to win support for their
party.
Finally it's time for the elections, or the
"Popular Vote".
In America this is always held on the first
Tuesday after the first Monday in November.
Every 4 years.
Voters from every state vote for their favourable
president and vice president candidates.
But voters aren't actually voting directly
for their chosen candidate.
They are actually voting for "electors", who
are pledged to a specific candidate and are
expected to, but don't always, vote for that
candidate in a second, final election.
This process is known as the "Electoral College".
Each state has a certain number of electors
in the college, based on the size of its population.
In total there are 538 electors in the electoral
college.
Because of this system, a candidate can become
president without winning the popular vote,
if the chosen electors don't vote as expected.
This happened in the 2000 George W. Bush vs.
Al Gore election.
Congratulations, you've passed the world's
hardest job interview.
For all your efforts you're now a prisoner
of the White House, unable to even walk across
the street without a legion of Secret Service
agents and a group of aides tagging along.
You will have to endure 24/7 scrutiny of your
every word and action.
And work 12 hour days where your schedule
is planned to the minute.
Don't forget the ongoing and relentless assault
from hostile news and media and opposition
parties dedicated to impeding your every move.
Only difficult decisions will reach your desk,
the easy ones are all taken care of at lower
levels of your administration.
What's your reward for all this?
Well you get an annual salary of $400,000
per year, plus an annual expense, travel and
entertainment account, these bonuses bring
your total salary to $550,000 per year.
Which seems like a lot, but is actually a
rather measly wage compared to your responsibilities.
Most presidents could earn a lot more if they
worked in the private sector.
So what's the real reward for all your hardships?
You will go down in the history books alongside
George Washington and you get to put your
personal stamp on a country of 313.9 million
people, and subsequently the world.